und da war ich dann wirklich sehr sehr
enttäuscht und auch wirklich traurig
weil was willst du machen du sitzt vorm
fernseher
du weißt deswegen gerade extrem viele
menschen unter werden irgendwelche
blöden sachen über dich erzählt die
eigentlich gar nicht so stimmen erhält
was geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video der heute mal mit
einem eigentlich voll veralteten thema
also ich freue mich eigentlich richtig
jetzt dieses video zu drehen um ehrlich
zu sein und zwar habe ich mir gestern
wirklich ganz also ich schaue wenige
youtube-videos halt so ganz das ist
unglaublich 26 27 minuten agb hat ein
video hochgeladen in dem sie über den
umgang mit influenza oder youtube ja im
fernsehen berichtet hat oder darauf
eingegangen ist deswegen hat auch einen
beitrag von dem fernsehsender sat 1 der
über sie berichtet hat und total falsche
sachen behauptet hat und sie hat so ein
bisschen in ein schlechtes licht gerückt
hat und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen das
war jetzt so der hautausschlag geber für
dieses video dass ich das jetzt
sozusagen so ein bisschen
ich will jetzt nicht sagen nach mache
bei mir ist das noch mal was etwas
anderes aber ich habe mich halt so ein
bisschen darin wieder gesehen und hab
mir gedacht wenn du dazu irgendwann doch
mal was sagen willst dann mach ich jetzt
weil jetzt ist gerade aktuell und ist ja
gut wenn man ich sage mal so als
youtuber oder generell im internet
gegenüber anderen medien so ein bisschen
zusammenhält und ja deswegen gibt es
heute das video von mir um direkt auf
den punkt zu kommen ich war vor einem
jahr
letztes jahr im juli ende juli war das
glaube ich im fernsehen und zwar auf zdf
bei dunja hayali das ist eine talkshow
die läuft ungefähr immer so gegen 22 uhr
und da ging es halt auch um influenza
social media und so weiter und die haben
mich dann gefragt ob ich lust hätte und
beitrag damit zu drehen und ihr müsst
wissen ich bin eigentlich jemand ich
will so was gar nicht unbedingt also ich
mag es gar nicht wenn irgendwelche
zeitschriften oder magazine oder
meinetwegen auch fernsehsender über mich
selber berichten also ich mache hier
meine youtube sachen und ich will gar
nicht so krass in die öffentlichkeit
versteht ihr das natürlich bin ich in
der öffentlichkeit das ist ganz klar
aber
ja so wirklich jetzt immer zu sagen hey
hier interview das will ich mitnehmen
und das mache ich das ist halt gar nicht
meine welt auf jeden fall wurde ich vom
zdf sozusagen angefragt also um genau zu
sein war es glaube ich die agentur die
das holz für die gedreht hatte also
diesen beitrag der mich angefragt ob ich
da lust drauf hätte und ihr müsst wissen
es ist natürlich eine bühne auf oder
eine ganz andere plattform eine ganz
andere dimension auf die man sich
plötzlich begibt ich glaube die sendung
in der ich da war haben um die zwei
millionen menschen gesehen natürlich
eher ältere leute aber wann schon einem
wirklich mal zwei millionen menschen auf
einmal zu ich hab halt erst wirklich
überlegt und meine eltern haben auch
manchmal diese talkshow geguckt und
kanten das und ich habe mit denen auch
darüber geredet und habe dann gesagt
komm erstmal mit wird vielleicht ganz
cool ich habe auch versucht mich über
mein damaliges youtube netzwerk so ein
bisschen abzusichern dass die halt
nichts schlimmes berichten können oder
nichts falsches hat jetzt sehr gut
geklappt sagen wir es mal so also
eigentlich nicht gut finde ich und ja
dann habe ich halt gesagt er komme ich
mach das mal
man muss auch sagen ich habe wirklich
wenig geld dafür bekommen also eine ganz
normale gage ist auch völlig okay aber
ich finde das sollte auch ganz wichtig
zu sagen sein also ich habe auf keinen
fall viel geld für so etwas bekommen
oder für diesen beitrag haben auch lange
dafür gedreht also es waren zwei
komplette tage
und ja das ganze haben wir in berlin
gedrehten zu auf der you messe
da war ich nämlich eingeladen und wurde
dort von einem kamerateam einem
redakteur und einer moderatorin die
sozusagen mir fragen gestellt hat die
wohl vor 20 jahren sehr populär gewesen
ist eure eltern werden den haben
sicherlich kann nicht kannte ihn auch
nicht ulla kock am brink ist aber
erstmal nebensächlich auf jeden fall war
das ziel man sollte so die alte
generation mit der neuen generation
youtube aufeinandertreffen lassen kann
man so sagen und ich habe mir den
beitrag mal aus dem internet gezogen
weil ich wirklich sagen muss ja ich habe
mir den angeschaut dann live und war
wirklich gespannt drauf auch ein
bisschen aufgeregt ich meine man ist ja
nicht auf dem fernsehen oder ich
zumindest und war wirklich so ein
bisschen enttäuscht eigentlich und
traurig und
hab mich ein bisschen verarscht gefühlt
ich habe das jetzt gar nicht so wirklich
gezeigt oder ich bin auf youtube auch
nicht darauf eingegangen ich habe
einfach gesagt okay man lernt daraus man
macht es nicht nochmal aber ja da wurden
halt ein paar sachen gesagt die zu 100
prozent bei den zuschauern in so einem
falschen hals geraten ich würde sagen
wir schauen einfach mal zusammen rein
und dann werde ich doch ein bisschen
darauf eingehen 667.000 fans haben
seinen kanal abonniert in seinen videos
geht es vor allem um ihn in seinen
tagesablauf und seinen humor beim ein
video hinter scheiders viel zu helfen ja
also so wird im beitrag angefangen fand
ich voll okay also die haben paar videos
gezeigt und mich so kurz zusammengefasst
was ich mache ulla kock am brink ist als
fernsehmoderatorin in den 90er jahren
berühmt geworden
auf social media plattformen wie youtube
oder facebook wird sie nicht aktiv und
dann kam halt ja dieses einzel interview
mit der moderatorin also das war sie
hier ulla kock am brink heißt sieht
falls du das sehen sollte
schöne grüße ich hoffe der gesuchte hat
mich halt da begleitet und wir uns auch
recht gut verstanden also war alles
super essen gut was ich jetzt hier an
schon blöd finde ich habe so viele
videos auf meinem kanal und dann wird
jetzt hier dieses donath video
aufgegriffen ich habe vor eineinhalb
jahren meinem video gemacht da habe ich
auch ein japanisches video aufgegriffen
wo jemand dollars vergessen hat und ich
habe euch gefragt ja soll ich das mal
ausprobieren wie viel ich hoffe mein
video macht das doch mal und ich habe
einfach das video gedreht natürlich
nicht viel aufwand aber es ging einfach
um unterhaltung und hier wird dann
ausgerechnet dieses video gezeigt weil
hat auch jedes andere video nehmen
können wir viel mehr inhalt drinnen und
es wird gesagt das hat ja nichts mit
leistung zu tun gut dieses video hat
vielleicht nicht besonders viel mit
leistung zu tun
trotzdem muss ich selber aufnehmen ist
selber schneiden das template selber
bearbeiten und das sind dann immer schon
so drei bis vier stunden und das ist ja
schon eine leistung natürlich ist es
jetzt kein video mit besonders vielen
das will ich auch gar nicht sagen aber
direkt an dieses wieder rauszunehmen für
diesen beitrag um damit anzufangen ich
meine das wäre genauso wenn ich übers
zdf berichten würde
und wirklich die schlechteste
dokumentation oder sonstwas aufgreifen
würde und das so verallgemeinert
darsteller als gibt es dann nur sowas
wie inhalt kann ich da jetzt nicht sehen
aber vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein
anderes video wo ich vielleicht sogar
was lernen kann gibt es nicht
alex ist ein typischer videoblogger und
da dachte ich dann wirklich so wenn man
das nicht akzeptieren möchte das ist
youtube gibt und das ist von so vielen
jugendlichen gefeiert wird man ist aber
trotzdem durchgehend als schlecht
darstellen möchte dann macht man das auf
jeden fall so richtig es ist ja wirklich
kein geheimnis dass analoge medien oder
auch analoge leute die im analogen
bereich arbeiten so ein bisschen
neidisch sind auf youtube ja das habe
ich auch selber schon oftmals erfahren
ich hatte letztes mal so ein kleines
interview in österreich bei einem
radiosender und der type auch ja so ein
bisschen schlecht auf das ganze zu
sprechen sage ich mal nach dem mann
erzählt hat wie das ganze abläuft und
wie viele leute da zu schauen und so
weiter hier wird jetzt gesagt auf meinem
kanal gibt es kein einziges video wo
irgend etwas geleistet wird wurde ein
video mit inhalt ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich bin ein unterhaltungskanal und
ich möchte dass ihr es hat da gm video
auf gesagt kann ich eigentlich hier
genauso aufgreifen ich möchte dass ihr
spaß habt meinen videos und ja das war
es eigentlich auch schon wir sind hier
nicht in der schule hier geht es nicht
darum irgend etwas zu lernen
man ist froh wenn man aus der schule
wieder kommen und erst mal ein bisschen
youtube gucken kann ich kann das ja auch
selber von mir und so ist es eigentlich
im fernsehen auch wenn es jetzt nicht
gerade um eine dokumentation eine
talkshow oder sonst irgendwas anderes
geht es geht um unterhaltung selbst die
erfolgreichsten zdf formate wo zum teil
über 67 millionen leuten immer zuschauen
sind irgendwelche in irgendwelche serien
oder reality soaps wie zum beispiel aus
berlin tag & nacht in ein bisschen
besser und geht es dabei wirklich darum
dass der zuschauer irgendwas lernt oder
irgendwie besonders viel inhalt drin ist
es geht einfach nur darum unterhalten zu
werden deswegen finde ich diese aussage
nicht gut und auch vor allem ich gut
informiert denn ich habe auf meinem
kanal sowohl videos wo es zum inhalt
geht und wo es
botschaften geht wie zum beispiel das
video meine ängste
das ist glaube ich so das was ich ganz
oben positionieren würde das ist auch
schon über zwei jahre alt aber da
stecken das starke message inter ich
versuche so anzustellen
das ist dass man mich vielleicht auch in
fünf jahren noch mal weil das wäre so
mein ziel da würde ich jetzt zum
beispiel so dargestellt als wäre ich am
arsch wenn mein youtube nicht mehr läuft
und ich habe dazu eigentlich noch gesagt
dass ich halt auch studiere und keine
ahnung was noch aber es wird
herausgeschnitten
ok also dann von heute auf morgen bei
mir youtube verwalter oder wenn es
youtube gar nicht mehr geben würde
wer absolut kein problem ich habe schon
für mich selber gut was beiseitegelegt
sagen wir es mal so und ich studiere
habe mein studium in einem jahr ungefähr
fertig kein problem alles cool aber dazu
kommen wir später noch und die ganz
analog zum star gewordene ulla kock am
brink herzlich willkommen so jetzt
kommen wir zu einem gespräch zwischen
der eigentlichen moderatorin dunja
hayali nennt sie sich weiß nicht
vielleicht kann das ja auch einige von
euch und der ulla kock am brink die mich
halt begleitet hat eigentlich sollte
dort noch die von waikiki zu der wohl
seinen flug verpasst hat oder es war an
dem abend ein bisschen windig und der
kontrolle nicht nach berlin fliegen oder
münchen von wo auch immer das jetzt
gesendet wird und ja das war dann für
mich natürlich noch umso mehr schade
weil niemand dagegen argumentieren
konnte
ja ich habe mir das jetzt gestern noch
mal angeguckt und ich könnte jedes
argument was da gleich gebracht wird
direkt in der luft auseinander pflücken
also das ist wirklich so total
uninformierter quatsch und da war ich
dann wirklich sehr sehr enttäuscht und
auch wirklich traurig weil was willst du
machen du sitzt vorm fernseher
du weißt deswegen hat extrem viele
menschen unter werden irgendwelche
blöden sachen über dich erzählt die
eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm ich habe
viel gelacht
erstmal war ich ein bisschen enttäuscht
von dem setting da das hätte mit glanz
so viel zu tun wie die kugel sonntag da
sagen ein paar sitzsäcke rum und
ansonsten gab es da ein mädchen also
kindergarten outfit ich säße jetzt du im
ernst ich habe mich ja wirklich alles
sehr nett
kennen gelernt ja ich will jetzt endlich
auch gar nichts vielleicht war es ihre
aufgabe da so stark gegen zu
argumentieren aber gerade das ist ja das
was das youtube so besonders macht wir
sind hier eigentlich auf einer augenhöhe
das ging bei diesem event jetzt nicht
darum den besten backstage bereich zu
haben oder sonst was ja wir sind auch
mit so ein paar donuts zufrieden mein
gott so ist es halt ist halt nicht
fernsehen wo jedes event glänzen muss
oder sonst was ist es zeit für jüngere
leute und mir ist es komplett egal ob es
da jetzt tun als zu essen gibt oder
keine ahnung kaviar oder was auch immer
so um dass jetzt gutes wäre ich ein
bisschen extrem dargestellt aber sowas
sollte man doch eigentlich cool finden
anstatt ist ja zu kritisiert erstaunlich
schön fand ich den umgang der youtuber
miteinander die werden ja rates genannt
was natürlich völlig absurd ist artist
also artist oder irgend jemand der was
kann ist glaube ich die definition davon
und ja es stimmt man wird auf
irgendwelchen events kriegt man oftmals
eine band dasteht art ist traurig meinem
ehrlich zu sein ich sehe mich auch nicht
als ein artist oder so ich kann jetzt
nicht besonders gut singen oder
irgendwelche kunststücke oder sonst was
trotzdem ist es auf jeden fall in
gewisser weise auch als ates zu
definieren wenn man einfach leute
unterhält yahoo medien sind ja auch
artists und warum sollte ich dann nicht
auch so definiert werden können kann man
natürlich so sehen ob man das jetzt zu
sagen muss gut mit dieser relativ
leichten arbeit sehr viel geld verdienen
wollen und deshalb und sie tun es auch
wer das gesagt oder es wird gesagt mit
dieser relativ leichten arbeit dann
frage ich mich
ich habe auch noch nie moderiert ja oder
irgend eine besonders tolle show
moderiert so wie sie es getan hat und da
sage ich ja auch nicht dass das relativ
wenig aufwand ist gar nicht wissen kann
sie kann ja gar nicht wissen wie viel
dahinter steckt wenn ich euch mal so
erzähle was ich eigentlich mache gut ich
schlafe gern bis 10 uhr
dann stehe ich aber auf drei mal gerne
ein video oder macht irgendwas anderes
da ist so viel dahinter
und dann gehe ich noch zur uni also wenn
ich das jetzt mal mit meiner schule
vergleiche in meiner abitur phase hatte
ich nicht mal so viel zu tun wie ich es
jetzt eigentlich möchte ich habe ich
sitze oftmals abends bis 11 uhr
imac und schneit irgend ein youtube
video fertig da haben die meisten schon
seit acht stunden feierabend und das
kriegt natürlich keiner mit ich bin
regisseur ich schreibe die skripte ich
mache alles selber das ist eine one man
show und keine sache wie es jetzt im
fernsehen ist wohl ein ganzes team da an
dem beitrag sitzt er über einen monat
das hat dann auch gesagt fertig gemacht
wird ja das ist alles eine person und es
ist verdammt viel arbeit vor allem wenn
man dann noch nebenbei lernt oder
studium macht eine besondere
authentizität in den protagonisten zu
zeigen dass ich bin echt und du bist
echt und wir sind echt und wir sind eine
hund so also wir sind eine familie
irgendwie und das ist natürlich
verlogener mystery okay dann ist das so
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen natürlich
gibt es fälle die extrem viel werbung
für irgendwelche sachen machen und
irgendwas als gut darstellen was nicht
mal gut ist aber das habe ich noch nie
gemacht und ich habe auch noch nie
irgendwie was vorgegaukelt kauft das
oder kauft das wir sind alle so cool
miteinander
ja es gibt einzelfälle aber das sollte
man wieder nicht verallgemeinern oder
das ist totaler quatsch ich stehe jetzt
so da als würde ich euch alle nicht
mögen oder ausnutzen wollen zumindest
stehe ich so dafür einen leuten das
gesehen haben ja und ich glaube das kann
auch jeder von euch nachvollziehen das
ist soweit stimmt überhaupt nicht ist es
alles wir kennzeichen heutzutage muss
alles gekennzeichnet werden vor einem
jahr war es vielleicht auch ein bisschen
lockerer aber da war es auch schon hart
und ich habe alles gekennzeichnet alle
produkte was auch immer ich achte sehr
drauf aber ich habe auch schon mal zum
schreiben von den medienanstalten
bekommen dass ich da mehr darauf achten
muss und das sollte man auch wirklich
ernst nehmen und schleichwerbung habe
ich auf meinem kanal noch nie gemacht
wirklich noch nie verständlich dass er
guckt so ein bisschen so als für das ich
denke was laberst du da
den reflexen zu denen auch kennengelernt
hast und der sagt zwar er hat auch
inhalt und macht hier und da irgendwas
was genau weiß man nicht so genau so den
mal zur seite wir uns gesagt 'junge in
zehn jahren mit der privatsphäre da
wirst du dich noch ein ko ich habe ihnen
das gefragt ich habe hier aber
privatsphäre bedeutet diesen youtuber
nichts ganz im gegenteil privatsphäre
bedeutet mir sehr viel ich will mir zwar
sehr oft man tag von mir so trotzdem ist
ja nicht immer alles zu 100 prozent so
wie es jetzt in dem video so passiert
viel ist es einfach unterhaltung viel
das ist so lustig sein das ist ja nicht
immer zu 100 prozent mein leben nur weil
dein video jetzt so aussieht an dem tag
heißt ja nicht dass jeder tag von mir so
ist wie alle allerwenigsten von euch
sollten meinen nachnamen kennen oder
sonst irgendwas sollten wissen wo ich
wohne oder was auch immer also viel über
mich außer meine videos ist ja nicht
bekannt kann man ja ganz ehrlich zu
sagen weil ich immer darauf geachtet
habe viel privatsphäre oder so viel wie
möglich privatsphäre behalten kann
die hat es wirklich so ich frage mich
ganz ehrlich warum hast du mir da nicht
solche negativen sachen oder so negativ
wie du darüber denkst warum hast du mich
das nicht live als sie miteinander
geredet haben gefragt das wäre doch viel
besser gewesen dann hättest du doch
jetzt nicht mit diesen vorurteilen die
du hast so auspacken müssen der double
click effect warum sollte man das nicht
machen in unserer branche warum sollte
ich nicht mit leuten mit denen ich mich
gut verstehe
ein video drehen ja das wird im
fernsehen genauso gemacht da sagt auch
rtl passt auf wir haben hier jetzt noch
einen neuen sender
da wird werbung gemacht sagst du da auch
das geht aber nicht leer oder stellst du
das als lächerlich da also wirklich
meiner meinung nach total uninformierte
sachen die da über mich verbreitet
wurden ihr könnt ja gern mal in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr dazu sagt
ich finde das wirklich sehr sehr traurig
einfach aus diesem grund du kannst doch
gar nicht wissen wie es ist du warst nie
in dieser position
da sollte man das auch nicht über andere
menschen sagen alles was ich mache
das sehr authentisch wenn ich sachen
auspacke oder irgendein video drehen
über irgendwas dann stimmt das auch so
und ich mache es einfach nur weil es mir
spaß macht und die leute die das blöd
finden oder mich und authentisch bin
die brauchen mich ja gar nicht schauen
ich würde ja niemanden ausnutzen oder
irgendwie sonst was machen eigentlich
geht es auch die ganze zeit um geld das
ist auch nur das lustige so
fernsehsender es geht eigentlich in
jedem beitrag auf mindestens eine minute
darum was sind die influenza so
verdienen immer werden über eine
influenza gesprochen wird wird auch
gesagt euro die verdienen das war ganz
schön viel und machen ganz ganz wenig
dafür wurde ich weiß nicht wie gut ich
das jetzt alles zusammengefasst habt ihr
könnt euch gern den ganzen beitrag auch
noch mal anschauen habe ich in der video
beschreibung verlinkt ich komme als
letztes in dem in der sendung ist aber
sehr leicht zu finden das war mir ist
einfach sehr wichtig so etwas noch mal
los zu werden und zu zeigen dass es ganz
anders ist ihr könnt gerne das video
euren eltern mal zeigen oder so mal
sehen was sie dazu sagen vielleicht auch
leute die diesen beitrag gesehen haben
das video von da will ich auch gern mal
in der beschreibung wenn jetzt noch
nicht gesehen hat und was ich auch noch
sagen wollte
ich wurde dann auch in einigen großen
zeitschriften wie zum beispiel focus
oder so die haben den bericht über die
über diesen beitrag geschrieben und da
ging es halt auch um mich und auch dort
wurde ich sehr sehr schlecht dargestellt
auch vermutlich ganz einfach aus dem
grund weil zeitschrift nicht mehr
wirklich aktuell ist bringt geht sowieso
ein bisschen dauern internet social
media hat immer noch eine steigerung
video on demand und so weiter und das
ist halt dann zum teil vermutlich
einfach nicht warum man das als so
schlecht darstellen muss freut euch doch
lieber weicht auch vielleicht ein
bisschen ins internet mehr ausmachen ja
viele versuchen sind ja das sollte man
so akzeptieren ich will auch niemanden
der entfernt sind arbeitet irgendwas
schlecht ist vor reden macht euer ding
und lass die anderen in ruhe und ja das
war einfach mal so dieses video schreibt
sehr gerne eure meinung in die
kommentare
für mich waren daumen nach oben freuen
und wir sehen uns und dann gibt es
wieder einen unterhaltsames video morgen
oder übermorgen haut rein